الجيش السوداني يحذر الدعم السريع من صراع
مسلح تحديده يتسرب وثائق الكانتاجون
السريه ترامب يعود الى نيويورك في مواجهه
تهمه الاحتيال هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقلها
لكم من قناه العربيه
[موسيقى]
توتر عسكري خطير يشده السودان حاليا بعد
ان حضرت قياده الجيش قوه الدعم السريع من
ان تعبئه قواتها داخل الخرطوم ومدن
سودانيه اخرى دون تنسيق معها قد يؤدي الى
صراع مسلح لا يحمد عقباه بين الفتين
المتحدث باسم القوات المسلحه السودانيه
قال في بيان رسمي ان البلاد تمر بمنعطف
خطيره وان الخطر يتزايد مع انتهاك قوات
الدعم السريع بانتشارها الاخير دون موافقه
الجيش وان ذلك التوتر مع الجيش السوداني
بعد الجدل الكبير الذي اثرته قضيه تسرب
وثائق البنتاجون السريه داخل وخارج امريكا
وما تسببت به من احراج للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ما حلفائها كشفت صحيفه واشنطن
بوست عن هويه مسرب هذه الوثائق وقالت انه
شاب في العشرينات من العمر يعمل في قاعده
عسكريه امريكيه الصحيفه اضافت ان الفتى
الذي لم يكشف او يكشف عن اسمه
كان مهووسا بالاسلحه الناريه وانه شارك
تلك الوثائق في البدايه عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
عبر منصته للتواصل الاجتماعي التروس اعلن
دونالد ترامب عودته الى نيويورك بافادته
في قضيه اتهامه بالاحتيال الضريبيه في
محكمه منهاتن والتي علق عليها ترامب بانها
ستكون انتصارا جديدا له تزامنا طلب محامي
ترامب تاجيل المحاكمه الجديده التي تخص
قضيه اغتصاب لكاتبه في التسعينات وذلك
بسبب الهجوم الاعلامي الذي قد يتسبب في
تشويش هيئه المحلفين
قبل اقل من شهر على الحدث الابرز في
بريطانيا حسب الامير هاري قرره بحضور حفل
تتويج والده تشارلز ملكا لبريطانيا الشهر
المقبل المتحدث باسم القاسم الذي اكد ايضا
ان زوجه هاري ماجن ماركر ستظل في
كاليفورنيا برفقه طفليها الاعلان الاخير
انها التكهنات حول ما اذا كان هاري الابن
الاصغر للملك سيحضر حفله تتويج في اعقاب
انتقاداته اللاذعه للعائله المالكه منذ ان
تنحى عن واجباته الملكيه عام 2020 فيما
سيتوج الملك تشارلز في كنيسه في لندن في
السادس من مايو المقبل ضمن مراسم رسميه
يعود التاريخ الى 1000 عام
بوظيفه نادره وشروط غريبه عينت بلديه
مدينه نيويورك كاتلين كوردي كمديره محترفه
لمكافحه القوارض التي تنتشر بشكل غير
مسبوق في شوارع واحياء نيويوركا وفي اول
مؤتمر صحفي لها قالت كوردي ان المدينه
ستبدا بتقليل هدر الطعام في الشوارع والذي
سيقلل بدوره من انتشار القوارض
وستستثمر ثلاثه فاصله خمسه مليون دولار
البلديه لتخليص هذه المدينه من الفئران
مشدده على انها ستتبع اسلوبا علميا
ومنهجيا لتقليل عدد الفئران في نيويورك
والاستفاده من التجربه في بقيه المدن
والولايات التي تعاني من نفس المشكله